I'm going to find a quicker have a lot
of fun times but live in the online
afterwards I'm having to take questions
so this time called no sequel and see
both getting to have it all my subtitles
this is my guys have totally fun crazy
scalable series so first let me
introduce myself briefly I prefer
hanging rails almost coincidentally back
in 2005 I went back and looked at the
email when I did it was great low point
13 which was 80 kilobytes of total
awesomeness rails for one it's 73 kinds
of bigger recently been doing some
architecture encoding operations and
management i was at script for a while
it was a top one her website in the
world one of the biggest rail sites out
there then it was over a culture
users nominet swift type swift type is
site search minute blocks as a service
so if you stop Steiner site search you
may be tempted install solar
elasticsearch which actually a lot
harder than you think it is I income to
subscribe and set up for you we're
selling we're also hiring so if that's
my blood don't that my real interest our
rails at large like how do you rail the
convicts have lots of developers lots of
code base high complexity not
necessarily scamming too many users all
that's often part of it the chinese i'm
going to show you here tonight have been
proven and like we use them at several
different companies at like hundred
million rows or more so this is not an
experimental ideas that hey may or may
not work there's great place for those
this is real stuff so who's this lock
for this is for basically anybody who's
messing around looking for data later in
your application anybody who touches it
in any way this is for business day then
your app can be just about anything so
traditional single you know HTML 11
multi-page apps a single phase
JavaScript app a native mobile app uses
rail api's all this touches for data
since its applicable to any of that this
also worked for both branded
applications that are totally green
field or like grizzled old giant rails
foot faces i seen a few folks so i'm
going to talk about core business that's
what the set is applicable to so what
does that mean for business day that is
things like users account permissions is
everyone
has stuff like this it's also stuff like
email preferences a t-test assignments
users who block other users if any
future can't really check wonder
application without that's my definition
of for business data it is not things
like web logs behavioral analysis data
audit trails that sub is stuff you
typically done an offline that's a
completely different talk it's also not
like large objects so if you're viewing
of light you know giant videos in the
database or graph they Dylan you're
mirroring facebook social graph don't
listen to me tonight instead go badly so
where we put this stuff traditionally we
have two choices choose the relational
database we're no sequel database that's
today and exit traditionally five years
ago who just relational databases if you
choose a relational database you get a
lot of stuff for free to people often
don't think about you get acid
transactions you get a lot of
operational flexibility so it's equal
with relational databases you've been
like you have slaves and streaming
backups of all kinds of stuff that we
kind of take for granted there's a
really robust ecosystem because it's
really only a few players in relational
they face the world you can find
consultants and books and training and
what have you you'll so typically have
really efficient storage that in terms
of your your actual data the store is on
disk and one
memory it's quite a fact the reason
people started looking awaiting
relational databases I think for poor
business data is it you also have a lot
to give up typically a limited data
types you don't like sometimes you want
to store like a hash of arrays a passage
of a raise or something crazy like that
you just can't do that in any
straightforward manner in the relational
databases readily you have like strings
and complaints and games and stuff like
that you have any weights email you've
got one migrations they're a big deal
that be careful and might have some
scalability concerns like is this
database in support good idea to support
mover the no sequel I would rather go a
lot of people do this because it fixes a
lot of its terms you have flexible data
types so you can store any kind of crazy
you have no migration is typically which
is awesome and hopefully a better scale
that's a lot of promise something sequel
the thing is that you actually give up a
lot of other stuff too many many no
sequel datastore sup support
transactions at all which I would argue
is a huge huge deal deployments and
support like the noticeable community is
currently really fragmented into a lot
of different pieces and there's no not
double dominant player like there are
relational database world so no matter
which one you pick you may not be able
to find community that's big in relation
that's a big deal there's also basically
less efficient storage a lot of this
stuff instead of JSON or similar data
facts which have no at your head so
tonight what I'm going to show you is
I'm going to put the talking to three
parts the first part is going to show
you how to deal with this problem
limited data types and a heavyweight
schema in a relational database and how
to improve its how easily envelop a pop
of it in that way second thing I'm going
to discuss is efficient storage it's
actually to make your relational big
explosion even more efficient which when
you're using its developer is a big win
and then the final one is scalability
concerns of an address how do you scale
relational database in a way to know
don't work so in order to do this i'm
going to introduce a user's table i'll
come back to several times it's not like
you need to memorize it this is sort of
amalgam of users table I see over the
years this is not you know there's no
phone company that has its users table
I put a bunch of different stuff in
there that's pretty typical my main
point is this is not the light rail 11
both flight home user table it's really
nice and simple this is more like 10
stuff I think people actually have it
production again I come back to it the
first thing I talk about it's orange
juice on in your relational database and
especially a few years ago this is like
oh my really well this used to be heresy
and part of my point tonight is it's not
actually a reason not to store some data
this way if you're careful any kind of
white tools so what is being carefully
being careful means you only have our
store data in Jake's on relational
database that you won't ever eat period
because generally can't do it and I know
the closest fans out there are like oh
yeah you can impose this and that's
really cool but there's still a lot of
limitations on it in general I would
prefer not have to query on data it
takes on field also this is I think a
point that's less obvious you only look
what data in Jake's on that you need for
one row at a time so taking our users
cake say we're going to show users to
other users this is a really common
think of a lot of systems let me show
you age of 35 other users and you want
to talk whatever if you're going to put
say pictures on this week don't store
the users profile URL in this JSON log
because then just let this 35 users use
JSON data out serialize it all
once that's pretty expensive the other
big deal is don't ever store default in
a day sun block this is easy to do load
as much of default values I'll saving
the database you can end up with a table
that has like 100 million rows of JSON
logs that have eats axiom dating it over
and over and over again that's a
nightmare anybody work with me hit a
particular company they don't make me
that experienced this problem it's not
fun so let's go back to our users table
given those criteria what are the needs
for a JSON storm there's some stuff in
head it's pretty obvious like local user
what language do they want to see our
side we only have to look at that with a
currently logon user or probably not
ever going to query on that if we do
it's not that big a deal like it's not a
mission-critical query so it's a good
candidate a couple other things that are
public less obvious oh
Oh locked up in front of database and
maybe a strike to the customer records
again we only deal with that with the
currently lock and user we're not going
to select this out both appearing on
them the final one that I think is
actually once I knew as a sort of
staring at me right in the face is your
password vanish that's a great candidate
you're only local password for the
currently logged on user you touch it
rarely you never really on exhibition
anyway so all four of those things can
go in our JSON data store so how do you
units there's an obvious way to do this
and I know this might be the
back I apologize i'll go for a little
quickly you basically take your users
table you add a text column it's going
to be your taste on store you might make
a data with it lets out of here you drop
your own problems so that everything to
the JSON so today and this is tool
active record store that comes with
great a few days that lets you basically
make those macbook attributes on you're
a cracker model and serialized mr. like
Jake something we'd easily so set up for
none except not quite so you look and
see what you've really done if you've
done this we've removed by standard
columns with added one json store with
it
comments embedded 85 bicycle repetitive
every to grow which doesn't sound like a
lot so we have fun users and then it's a
big big deal and so most of the fights
are just the column names of data into
JSON stores just like Facebook oh okay
that's repeated in 100 million times
this is not only this is loaded every
single time you're treatm use it from
any visa let's try this again there's a
gem out there that published called flex
collins and here's how we do it with
that we're going to separate table for
this race on computer details it's got
two columns user ID and the json clock
each one to one with the users table
we're going after their I'm going to
remove it from the user tickles drop
those columns entirely we have a sweats
columns down and it has a little dsl for
finding a language for these columns
will do a one to one with the user and
never compensated reflects columns
problem and what this does is it makes
the attributes in this jigsaw passions
actually putting in another table show
up directly on the user
attributes of that user directly you
still can't pretty on them but you can
achieve any of the rest of your code
nothing else knows of those columns of
mom and your model directly and working
at this point we're only going to happen
love that JSON store from this and ship
it across the network and p serialize it
for those few attributes that we only
ever use your like the currently logged
in user this is actually a big plane
there's one more thing we're going to do
this jeff has quietly features one of
them is that we can define the names of
the columns to be using the JSON stored
separately coming from the application
i'm going to say in the application on
the published in half and half in the
database is called pw provoke alcoholic
velvet so this is the kind of thing that
kind of seems dumb except again you both
want this back hundred million roses
you've actually reduce the overhead a
great deal that makes a big difference
in your database one more set of stuff
that collects film does is a lot of
features in there but just to make sure
you them and also this transparent gzip
compression for things like HTML in your
databases make a huge difference is
probably direct rows are it's got full
validation support and even supports
this kind of things that aren't
like active record database types it
will remove no longer fields for the
JSON so you can move the field it will
go clean up the stuff add your state
back out he take some classes later it
also supports railways three point out
to 4.1 and even both the recent version
groovy and it would be my simple post
read sequel like kind of like an
industrial-strength person of active a
bit short so that's the first technique
I have to make your relational database
a little bit more like enough sequel
database and be able to use it much more
flexibly now you can store things like
access to the race attaches in there do
whatever you want second technique I'm
going to call low carbon valley tables
this is also big database but some point
for anybody it's not easy and it feels
so what's cardinality cardinality is the
number of distinct values in column
holes so I cardinality column something
like username or email address or first
name username email address a public
unique every user is different first
name it's not unique but there's a lot
of different for stains on there right
slow cardinality is stuff like deleted
so that's a cool game gender let's take
Facebook's dinner thingy seven different
values for generating but it's still
pretty low cardinality can correct like
100 million users there's also like your
abdomen
Brandon those are all low cardinality
columns and what they look at it we're
almost always throwing those is full
column why are we using an entire column
like the one in fact it's sorting like
the orbits coming back to our users
table item is actually pretty difficult
if you look at which columns in our
users take or a little cardinality is
actually quite a lot of that in this
case it's almost a third of the table in
my experience it's pretty typical you
have lots and lots of flag do users
because they behave in many ways I'm not
going to go through all of them right
here but suffice it to say I piece
pretty straightforward they're always
home to like flags only numbs in some
way what can we do with this with this
local our cables get here's what we're
going to do we're good evening you take
hold user statuses I think of use the
work status for this you can thought
anyone into migration you say low card
goes the truth this creates a table with
exactly the columns I'm going to pull
off the University we're going to create
a model for declare the part people
we're going to tell the tell the news
your class that has its little party so
what is it's done this is not doing what
you may think it's doing this actually
oh I would make one more point let me
pull this out that we're going to do is
take things like gender and formal level
instead of storing them to integers when
the scrotum section strange it's really
annoying to be like oh you know for a
little is projecting what does that
maybe or gender value is seven
I no idea what that means the number of
times I've actually had to go in with
database and like slide out first names
in the gender welcome to figure out
which one which means people it's kind
of ridiculous I'm going to sort of stuff
the strings here's what's actually
happening this low card table jen is
going to create one row in the local art
table for each unique combination of
flags from the users table automatic so
as you're storing users it's going to
populate this table automatically by
saying hey is there a there's a
combination I needed it already and so
use it otherwise co-created and then
that many users table or just kind of
pointers back to this so you look like
the first road safe okay user ID one has
you just a second three that that would
be no that very Schultz is email not at
all that's a beginner has a verify email
and send a newsletter to her because
this is all about them demand to any
combinations of things you don't
actually have that theoretically exists
but you don't actually have never end up
in his table so we don't have like
saving Nevison newsletter to not verify
email addresses sounds reasonable there
are no combinations of false and true in
here so we create just the growth we
need it's kind of efficient is you can
possibly get this is sort of describe
you later I just said text or did we're
generating rose
and this is a big deal so what we do at
one time is actually catch this entire
table in them this only has a few
hundred rose now rail is going to
operate anything incredibly quickly and
a production stable state gets zero
extra creases table ever because you
pretty badly end up with every
combination you're ever going to have in
there and it's all sitting in memory and
it all does there's lots of stuff in
there to handle database blockage that
multiple processes try to create the
same of the same time you don't want it
all works it's also a great horse report
to see prompt if you're sitting an
actual my seeking counsel of closeness
console trying to figure out what's
going on with this is way better than if
you actually try to implement big deal
to your database where you have giant
integer that you're trying to break down
into like these four bits and stuff like
that also the last point I'll make
indexes on boolean fields typically are
useless your database we won't use it
index colossal thinks it's been a narrow
and damage with very small percentage of
roses a full table scan it's cheaper
that's still true if you're going to
look for like all you know non-believing
users from your database there's nothing
that's going to help there but if you're
looking for particular combinations like
I want deleted anonymous users we're
still getting the email for some reason
the index may actually be able to help
here and that's pretty great so how does
this look from rails the short version
is all works exactly like you expect he
acts exactly like those are real
sighing gender and validation to
defaults go to class level scopes with
the validations on the status cable
instead you can kind of mix up wherever
you want a few last verses of this
there's also full full full support I've
often had the phone like I need import
users in batches of 100,000 their API
that lets you sort of collect those
users and very opportunely one or two
queries it will find and then create all
the values of the local park penguins
handle that aight guys the partial
periods as active support notifications
if you watch what's happening this it
also supports every recent version rails
and some not so recent versions Ruby in
JRuby again my sequel las Tres sequel
like both these dens actually also work
with things like Oracle and the sequel
server i actually have a pipe in
instances of work on sequel server at
night i don't know how many thousands
dollars or not assessed against Lord is
there a lot of demand so glass piece i'm
gonna show is how they can you pull this
together how we sit the signers up so
when I got rales only support one
database but we know that's not so many
right that's that's it's been a long
time since that there's no reason to
keep everything in one thing to make
same exercise surprised you still do
this I'm going to do sue to a gentle DB
charmer this is not really my me since
it's written by a guy named Alexi
covering who's kind of the most amazing
person I've ever
different companies you can't happen
these are to stay away so little models
look like a bee charmer DB tournaments
you say on any rail ok TV magic is the
key word for it here's the connection
this is a being just a natural database
that gamble that sets we're in the users
maximum database where is it like the
power you want now queries or any users
up will automatically go to that
database which really blows we also
defined slaves for it if you have some
my sequel slaves of clusters legs and
say this is a replica of that it will
automatically route all queries
round-robin among the slaves unless
you're like an expense accident than
ottoman who knows georgian it's actually
better talk to the master he's also got
a ton of really cool syntax like in a
good way that lets you proudly buries
however you want so you can create
scopes and then you can say okay this
stove is always you to the master you
can be mapped databases all kinds of
stuff you basically what i just said the
last point I'll make your DB trauma has
processed I connected the map hundreds
of billions of queries without welcome
almost it was built on TV charmer I mean
this is abuzz it's typically
the second plus all the time so this
isn't a general it's me I need something
I can trust to build a business on top
of this is something I can actually
trust I think Alexis not always he's
always as we're promoting it's emotional
and it's pretty solid let's talk a
little bit about how we allocate these
databases so now we have aspects ability
to put models where we want when we do
with that here's what we're going to
introduction are you
on a server at a lot of ram the ram in
fact that the entire users table animals
indexes just get cash feed ramp
persistently this means it's going to
serve straight out of grand never needs
in touch the visiting separate right
this is really in fact this is how you
get thousands of queries per second
without a problem and as it turns out
using these tools one thing we've done
is rotated part of our users people into
enough pieces that I did the map that
sample healers table you can let the
server from amazon for 24 bucks a month
they can cast 118 million users in its
memory is one of the Hyneman radiuses to
using these tools you can end up with a
server that's really cheap that can
scale to achieve different users our
details this is rj sun block this isn't
going to the server that doesn't mean to
have the hutch ram because it's going to
hit this every time you access it but
that's okay because we're only accessing
it for the currently logged in user it's
a wonder one kind of key value store
sort of thing that's not a problem at
all and in this low cardinality table
that we have this thinkin's with
anywhere because you're basically never
ever created in fact these your typical
craigavon is going to be when you deploy
and we start bales instances they will
hit this once to load up in the memory
and then s it that's our like production
deployment and so for each major cable
in the system you would kind of love
something like this except that that's
really
introduction databases over here these
can stack on top of each other when
you're just starting out you don't want
to buy a ton of infrastructure you want
to do something like this so you can
stack these JSON blob on same server you
can throw I can all look carnality table
in just one place and what I would
actually do is buy single server and put
creep database database is between one
server instance if you like one my
sequel d and one post with Stephen but
then you've got multiple databases
within it this makes sure that you're
not joining between instances
unnecessarily track all of those errors
right off the bat you're not actually
spending any more time on harbor
management some of the come back and say
wrap up this topic of it quite right
here why are you in this talk coming
back to the slide here's my fundamental
pieces I watched people pick out the
destruction of their applications my
personal opinion is that losing this
stuff is way more painful than you
realize you come in in your life okay
though a deal like I get it has lots to
do Billy features that's awesome
transactions in particular can be a very
painful thing to lose deployments in
support like all this stuff community
adds up I'm not saying don't use a no
sequel database I'm saying really
careful before you use that and really
know what you're getting into if there
for you know if you're building a
business and part of it for innovation
of your business is doing vast amounts
of data bio means you may or they
something makes maybe a terrible idea
for you but I think a lot of people are
they're like hey our organization is not
in data storage itself it's in something
else to work doing and I think giving
this stuff up be pretty painful the
tools I think I've shown here tonight
completely help out I'm not saying
thanks every problem in the world and
pretty but really helped out a lot of
this stuff over here to make relational
database is pleased to be used and want
the funds and uses it develops so lastly
as my treat